tony à 60 secondes pour trouver
quelqu'un dans la rue qui va devoir le
porter jusqu'ici on va jouer là-bas
bakhash c'est très sain tu vas pouvoir
gagner jusqu'à 2000 euros reid d'accord
ma chérie 2000 euros tu vas devoir
choisir trois défis parmi ces enveloppes
pour 100 euros
il faut trouver quelqu'un dans la rue et
faire un slow avec lui pendant 30
secondes en chantant un slot d'accord tu
choisis qui aurélie pauvres pour faire
c'est d'essayer
valérie benaïm je vais là il est parti
cette relégation
[Musique]
jaua les exemples ne le serait plus
serré
c'est le ballon kangoo tu vois 60
secondes pour trouver quelqu'un ait
sauté avec lui sur un ballon quand vous
regardez ma santé et voilà pour que vous
soyez tous les deux dans la rue comme
des contraintes sauter sur un ballon
kangourou tu vois qui pour remplir ce
défi gérard miquel maire si je le sens
pas vraiment attendu il adorait aller à
doha
[Applaudissements]
je tiens des chiens c'est bon merci
beaucoup merci à ces vacations quand tu
traverses d'april à 7
et là c'est plus compliqué on va jouer
pour 200 euros
il va falloir trouver et ramener une
personne qui porte un sous vêtement bleu
n'ont pas l'enlever one ou montré
d'accord dans la rue tu choisis et qui
pour y aller excusez moi monsieur bah
oui quand même
vous verrez votre souris plein quelle
couleur est venu de lui vous n'avez
ainsi mme blot par hasard bon un slip
bleu merde
et vous le tracé bleu
le singe et un survêtement qui me font
alors bon alors tu sais quoi même si
quelqu'un tout le monde s'est souvent
fait gagner un autre part elle convient
bien adhérer c'est là que normalement
c'est perdu mon valaisanne est ce un peu
cherché à des attentions et un camion
quand même mais ce qui est à toi rythme
là croyez bien que je remette tout soit
parfaitement bleu mais si tu trouves pas
si longtemps des sous vêtements mais par
le ba ba de monopole et là le pompier ou
pas devant toi sous vêtements me l'avez
compris il a été pas mal comme isabelle
en mai oui mais bon pas rester
malheureusement tu à 150 ou autres
kotick
mais pour valider ce défi pour valider
cette somme il va falloir que tu y
arrives à relever le défi mystère tony à
60 secondes pour trouver quelqu'un dans
la rue qui va devoir le portait
jusqu'ici
[Musique]
je me rende mon temps à léo tu dois
trouver quelqu'un d'autre
au pire des cas si ta personne au bout
de cinquante secondes tu peux prendre
motta stone il tue parce qu'on a 110 110
à trouver du paquet agrémenté
l'extérieur possible tout est dans le
mental a essayé vice et des fonds des
clients
à son avis ça peut le faire à temps la
tête mais le mec robin bien on va faire
la personne on va pour elle c'est un peu
comme la lgv asie et s'est battu d'abord
benji ça marche
les belges y aller mais jy à l'énergie
[Applaudissements]
demain
ah ouais ah bon
qu'en pensez vous
alors quoi plomber le savoir
[Applaudissements]
apa le challenge est relevé
tu multiplies tega par deux et ugal 300
ma chérie
[Musique]